japan today lives in the shadow of the
catastrophic march 2011 disasters
the earthquake tsunami and environmental
devastation at the fukushima daiichi
nuclear power plant on the japanese
coast north of tokyo
like 9 11 in the united states the event
is often publicly remembered by the
numeric date
but as 311 san ichiichi not 9 11.
the initial tremors were massive around
9.0 on the richter scale and they were
followed by a wall of water that was
over 130 feet high in some places
the tsunami inundated more than 200
square miles of coastline reaching up to
six miles inland
some 20 000 people died and a million
buildings were destroyed
among its impacts the tsunami
compromised the safety systems of the
fukushima plant
causing explosions radiation leaks and
the evacuation of a hundred and
sixty-five thousand people
so today let's look at fukushima in two
ways
first as a unique and unprecedented
natural and human disaster
second as an event that heightens the
paradox of japan since the 1990s
now here's the paradox
in the words of a japanese friend our
grandparents built a military empire and
that ended in disaster
then our parents built an economic
empire so we were a world power again
but that failed too the bubble burst and
then in 2010 we lost our place as the
world's second largest economy
so what happens now what empire do we
build or maybe we don't build an empire
at all should japan be just another rich
industrial or post-industrial economy
and if japan's modern history has been
about building empires is that era over
now my friend didn't use the term
existential crisis but it fits there's a
pervasive sense that japan has lost its
way and that it needs to change
radically in order to recover its place
in the world
but pushing against that is the fact
that so much in japan still works so
well
japan has the highest life expectancy
and the lowest murder rates in the world
it has free and fair elections
and to indulge the cliche the trains run
on time
and all that is evident if you visit
japan
you can schedule your transfers on the
shinkansen the bullet train to the
minute
you can jump off the platform and grab a
sushi obento a sushi lunchbox from a
station vendor
you can eat healthy sushi almost
anywhere in japan because the food
hygiene standards are so high
you can grab a newspaper or a magazine
at the train station and it'll have
articles reporting on government
corruption because there's a free press
and if you discover something that you
left behind on your last train
well in japan people still return
wallets with the cash inside to the lost
and found and at that level in japan
everything still works it's a low crime
peaceful multi-party democracy where
just about everything seems to be just
good enough
those reassuring aspects of daily life
dull one's sense of urgency and without
urgency vested interests can easily
block change
in other words nothing is quite broken
enough in japan to change the status quo
but in the background is a pervasive
sense of dissatisfaction
and vulnerability
so let me relate that broad sense of
dissatisfaction and vulnerability to the
details of 311
the magnitude of the quake itself
provoked an acute sense of fragility
when we talk about things being grounded
whether in pop psychology or electrical
engineering we mean stable secure and
unlikely to shock you
but what if the ground itself isn't
grounded what if the continents are just
giant paddle boards floating on a vast
global sea of molten rock and that's
exactly what they are
and massive earthquakes remind us that
the ground isn't solid and that those
giant paddle boards are always smashing
into each other solid ground isn't solid
now that's not a comforting thought but
massive earthquakes make that thought
unavoidable
now that sense of intense vulnerability
was intensified by how the japanese
establishment responded to the 311
disasters
for a few brief moments on march 11th
the nuclear power plants in fukushima
operated like engineering marvels
all 11 reactors survived the earthquake
intact and they began automatic
shutdowns
but the reactors were not designed for
the massive tsunami that struck minutes
later
that tidal wave overtopped the sea walls
around the reactors damaging the backup
systems battery power and diesel
generators
the seawater also destroyed the
electrical equipment used to control and
monitor the reactors
as a result workers lacked
instrumentation and even lighting
and they had no standard way to cool the
reactor's fuel rods for a safe shutdown
in the words of the bulletin of the
atomic scientists
when on-site workers refer to the severe
accident manual the answers they were
looking for simply were not there
the plant's emergency procedures simply
didn't allow for the possibility of a
prolonged total loss of power
so the managers and workers had to
improvise they used fire hoses to pump
seawater into the reactors in an attempt
to cool them
that helped stop the meltdown from
spreading
beyond the reactors to the pools of
spent nuclear fuel nearby
but it created huge pools of
contaminated water a different but very
serious problem
and despite those efforts hydrogen
explosions damaged the containment
structures of two additional reactors
now because workers there had no
emergency procedures for a total power
loss the disaster is what the industry
now calls a beyond design basis event
that means the system actually worked as
designed but the disaster exceeded our
expectations
and that situation exposed the greatest
weaknesses of japanese politics and
society today
everything dysfunctional about japan was
brought to the fore
the days and months after fukushima were
a distillation of everything in japan
that doesn't work
i'd even argue that the term beyond
design basis event applies to much of
japan since 311.
the system just wasn't designed for this
311 was a friday morning
the two top executives at the nuclear
power plants owner and operator tokyo
electric power or tepco were out of the
office
tepco chairman katsumata tsunahisa was
on a junket in beijing with other
industry executives the ceo shimizu
was with his family in the historic city
of nara sightseeing
once the disaster unfolded and he
recognized that the optics were terrible
shimizu struggled to get back to tokyo
train service was briefly suspended so
he tried to hire a private helicopter
but japanese aviation law prohibits
private helicopters from taking off
after 7 pm
so
he tried to get help from japan's
self-defense forces its military command
and he took off from nagoya at 11 pm in
a c-130 transport
but as soon as he was airborne the
defense ministry had the airplane turn
around because authorities wanted to
prioritize the evacuation of victims of
the earthquake and the tsunami
when the ceo finally got to tokyo at 10
am the next morning he began to realize
the full scope of the disaster
a day later he attended a press
conference and then
he disappeared from public view for a
month
he left mid-level officials to deal with
the disaster and handle questions from
the media there were widespread rumors
that chimizu had committed suicide or
suffered a nervous breakdown
but and here's the problem he came
through the crisis quite well
unlike hundreds of thousands of people
in fukushima prefecture people who were
forced to abandon their homes and the
entire region
shimizu did resign as the ceo of tepco
but he was promptly appointed to the
board of fuji oil whose largest
shareholder is tepco
so if you wanted to pick a poster child
for the dysfunction of the japanese old
boy network shimizu would be an ideal
choice he'd worked for a decade at tepco
joining the company right out of college
and he'd risen through its ranks despite
a questionable safety record at another
tepco nuclear reactor
indeed during his career shimizu
consistently made the argument that
nothing can be made completely safe
but shimizu and others fail to realize
how simple and inexpensive changes like
a higher seawall around the reactors
could have been amazingly cost effective
and the company's cozy relationship
with government regulators made him
somewhat immune from the consequences of
his own bad decisions
the old boy network protected its own
critics of japan's nuclear power
industry refer to it as a nuclear
village
so like residents of a small village
japan's government regulators and
private companies are hostile to
outsiders and they cooperate to serve
the interests of the village
but the interests of that village in
this case the nuclear power industry are
not necessarily those of japan
japan's prime minister at the time kan
nauto had campaigned on shaking up
institutions like tepco
nominally private companies whose overly
cozy relations with government
regulators protect them from the
consequences of their own mismanagement
but the 311 crisis put khan in an
impossible position
he didn't trust the information he was
getting from tepco
but he needed to work with tepco to
contain the disaster
unsure of tepco officials honesty and
competence khan took it upon himself to
micromanage the crisis
he even intervened in the attempt to
cool the reactors
that produced some bizarre moments for
example
during a teleconference between khan and
some senior tepco officials the nuclear
power plant director yoshida masao
agreed with khan to stop frantic efforts
to cool the reactors with fire hoses
then he turned to his engineers and said
ignore my public statements keep cooling
the reactors with fire hoses
so the optics of japanese leadership
were terrible during the fukushima
crisis the public saw the old guard as
self-serving liars and the nuclear
village did what it does best protect
itself
even at the expense of public safety and
trust
now even before the disaster at
fukushima support for khan and his
democratic party of japan had cratered
khan's approval rating was a dismal 18
it was so low it even rebounded a bit
after 311
but the scope of the disaster and
government mismanagement opened the door
for a resurgence of japan's liberal
democratic party its long-time
powerhouse
the ldp decisively won the december 2012
elections
but once the ldp returned to power it
pretended everything was fine the new
prime minister abe shinzo returned to
the status quo
you see the ldp wanted cheap electricity
to promote the profitability of japan's
industries
and it was convinced that it could
overcome
public concerns about nuclear power even
after fukushima
but the ldp was wrong
its attempt to restart japan's nuclear
power plants ran into furious opposition
public opinion polls showed that upwards
of 80 percent of the population wanted
to reduce or even eliminate nuclear
power plants
public demonstrations attracted as many
as 200 000 protesters
and the opposition cut across the
political spectrum
the nobel prize-winning author oe
quenzabaro who had long criticized
nuclear weapons was among the leading
activists no surprise there
the surprising member of the
anti-nuclear movement was kobayashi
yoshinori
a manga author
kobayashi is best known for his
right-wing revisionist take on japanese
history
kobayashi's popular graphic novels
insist that world war ii in the pacific
resulted from japan's attempts to
liberate east asia from western
imperialism and so the war was not an
act of japanese aggression
but now he joined
old leftists like oe as a fervent
opponent of restarting the reactors
the breadth of the anti-nuclear movement
blunted industry plans it was so strong
that whereas before 311
japan's 54 reactors had produced roughly
25 percent of the country's electricity
after fukushima only four reactors
produced about four percent of its
electricity
but the liberal democratic party went
ahead with its plans to minimize
alternatives to nuclear power it
eliminated the previous government's
subsidies for renewable energy
especially solar power
as a result japan has become more
dependent on imported fossil fuels
especially natural gas but also coal
and japan fell behind its targets for
limiting greenhouse gas emissions
much japanese progress towards its goal
of reducing emissions has come from
reduced industrial output from a slow
economy not from increased efficiency
even a decade after fukushima japan had
no sensible plan to meet electricity
demand while reducing greenhouse gases
the government and the major utilities
insist that the answer has to be nuclear
power but the electorate wants the
reduction or elimination of nuclear
power so the ldp's plan is in essence to
hope that voters will forget about 311
so the nuclear village can restart more
power plants and that's not so much a
plan as a fantasy
now for an old japan hand like me that
situation is bizarre because it once
seemed like old japan inc business
industrial cooperation was ready for the
green revolution
the first detailed international
agreement on climate change was
concluded in 1997 in kyoto and it's
known accordingly as the kyoto protocol
that protocol built on the 1992 united
nations framework convention on climate
change
but under the kyoto protocol the world's
major industrialized countries committed
to specific reductions in greenhouse
gases
japan committed to a six percent
reduction in greenhouse gases
and it seemed like japan inc saw the
kyoto protocols as a business
opportunity
for example toyota accelerated
development of the first practical
consumer hybrid vehicle the prius so it
could debut the car when the kyoto
accords were signed
now yes the kyoto protocol was a
challenge to reduce greenhouse gases
but it was also a massive opportunity
by the early 2020s however japan was no
longer a clear leader in green vehicles
or green technologies
the government's ministry of
international trade and industry did
choose to promote hydrogen fuel cells
and that's potentially a remarkable
technology
but that requires a massive
infrastructure hydrogen refueling
stations are expensive whereas it's
relatively cheap to add an electric
charging station to a parking garage so
fuel cells might be a great long-term
strategy
but its short-term prospects seem
limited
and it takes energy to make and compress
the hydrogen for the fuel cells
so using fossil fuels to make the fuel
cells doesn't help much in greenhouse
gas emissions
in fact the whole hydrogen fuel cell
plan really works only if you guessed it
only if japan reopens those 50 shuttered
nuclear power plants
so japan's political establishment
stuck
before the 1990 financial crisis japan's
political establishment could ignore
much of public opinion
it was confident that voters would be
satisfied with continued economic growth
but after decades of sluggish growth
that strategy doesn't work
and the japanese political establishment
doesn't have a plan b
so in that broader sense 311 was a
beyond design basis event for the entire
political establishment
here's another area where japan seems
stuck family policy
japan has experienced population
shrinkage since 2010
its young people aren't getting married
they aren't starting families they
aren't making enough children to keep
the population from declining
so by most projections the japanese
population will shrink for the
foreseeable future of course most
developed countries would shrink without
immigration in 2018 the united states
the united kingdom sweden denmark france
australia and new zealand all had
fertility rates of about 1.7 children
per woman of childbearing age
that's not enough to replace two adults
but in japan the rate was 1.4
and by some estimates half of japan will
be single in 2035 it will be a society
largely without conventional families
in japan as elsewhere the decline in
family formation is driven largely by
economic insecurity
women who follow conventional gender
roles want men with conventional stable
jobs
and those jobs are less common in japan
after the bursting of the economic
bubble in 1990
and men who follow conventional gender
roles aren't interested in marrying and
assuming the responsibilities of a
family that they might not be able to
support
the decline of lifetime employment and
the rise of a freelance economy have
made marriage and family formation less
attractive
the prospect of japan as a single
society rather than a family society
panics social and political
conservatives
now there are limits to what government
policy can accomplish but there are some
pretty good models for how to raise
marriage and fertility rates
these include business incentives to
create steady full-time jobs labor laws
that raise the minimum wage laws that
increase job security subsidies for new
families strong family leave polities
and gender equality in the workforce so
that women can contribute more to family
income
but the liberal democratic party is too
traditional and too beholden to industry
to embrace those kinds of changes
on the contrary it blocks even symbolic
gestures
such as letting women in japan keep
their original family names after
marriage
and it doesn't help when japan's
political elite keeps sounding like
grumpy old male chauvinists
for example the head of the organizing
committee for the 2020 tokyo olympics
announced that he doesn't like to
include women in meetings because they
talk too much
that guy mori yoshido was already known
as a gaff-prone sexist so why at 83 was
he the best choice for such a visible
job
like shimizu at tepco the old boy
network helps its own
so what's the alternative
some cultural critics are attempting to
put an optimistic spin on these issues
arakawa kazihisa a researcher and
marketing consultant has looked to
japan's past to find a more promising
future
arakawa argues that what he calls super
solo societies can produce vibrant new
cultures
in the 1600s for example the small
village of edo which is now tokyo
rapidly turned into a huge city as
samurai poured in from around japan to
serve the shogun and daimyo lords
many of these samurai had left their
families at home so the result was a
huge pool of single men who needed
lodging and food and they wanted
entertainment
so that super solo society produced much
of what we now call traditional japanese
food culture including sushi tempura and
soba noodles
each of these foods acquired its modern
forms in the booming capital of edo and
then diffused to the rest of the country
the demand for entertainment also
produced kabuki theater so
traditional japanese culture have little
to do with traditional families
so maybe family values are overrated
maybe japan's solo society will produce
an exciting new future
and if you check travel magazines japan
is commonly rated as a great place for
solo travelers that's based on things
like 24 hour stores that sell everything
from salads to underwear to sim cards it
all makes japan an easy place to thrive
as a single traveler
or as a freelancing digital nomad
and as many unmarried young japanese
might attest they might say hey i might
not have enough money or a stable job to
start a family but i've got more than
enough to have fun and travel with my
friends
now in 2016
the winner of japan's most prestigious
literary prize was a short novel called
konbini
that's translated as convenience store
woman although it's actually convenience
store human
it's the tim of a disaffected woman who
finds happiness in her mundane routine
as a convenience store employee she
doesn't want to marry she doesn't even
really want a social life she just wants
her routine at the convenience store
it won the akutagawa prize and it sold
millions of copies and it was adapted as
a radio drama
the author murata sayaka clearly struck
a nerve as one reader tweeted what is
normal anyway and why should people who
aren't normal have to suffer
now to judge by literary prizes and
movie adaptations japan is full of
people finding meaning beyond
traditional families there are widows on
quests of self-discovery there are
secretive bitcoin miners
but it's hard for traditionalists to
embrace that future
it requires giving up the idea of
japanese empire 1.0 japan's military
empire in the early 20th century
and also empire 2.0
japan has an economic superpower in the
second half of the 20th century
and forsaking those visions of empire
accepting japan as a slower growth solo
society that requires a new vision of
japan
and depending on one's perspective that
new vision of japan it's either
exhilarating or terrifying
[Music]
you